live local now three station casino
properties now vacant will be demolished
and the land sold thank you for joining
us at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadez well there have been
so many questions about the future of
them since properties in the valley
reopened now but these of course these
three are not now we're talking about
fiesta henderson on lake mead parkway
and the 515 texas station and fiesta on
rancho and lake mead in north las vegas
that is where we find sasha loftus uh
this afternoon live with reaction of
course to the plan sasha
christian we've done several stories on
these properties in the past with
reaction from neighbors here who were
really hoping that they would one day
reopen now they're going to have to wait
and see what could be next for these
locations now the announcement came just
after noon today from red rock resorts
these three have been closed since the
pandemic in 2020. the facilities at the
properties other than the ice rink at
fiesta rancho which will remain open
will be demolished that's according to a
statement from red rock resorts the
properties have been an important part
of their business for quite a few years
and they say they're sad to announce the
permanent closures i spoke with a person
who used to work at fiesta rancho he
shared a few memories from the property
thanks to them you know my
i was good over there and
i was uh so
so nice to work on with my environment
with uh with my co-workers and
and i hope
we have a
another opportunity
to work uh with with my same co-workers
you know
all three properties were built in the
1990s no word on when any demolition
will start here we did put a poll out on
twitter asking which of these three
properties were your favorite so far you
say texas station followed by fiesta
henderson again of those three
properties reporting live tonight in
north las vegas sasha loftis live local
now